et on en vient maintenant au cinéma mais
c'est plus que du cinéma avec la sortie
événement de la semaine indigènes un
film d'histoire un film de guerre mais
qui a aussi pour but avoué de participer
à la reconnaissance des tirailleurs des
spahis ou des goumiers qui ont participé
à la libération de la france pendant la
seconde guerre mondiale avec nous deux
des acteurs qui se sont beaucoup
investis dans le projet qui font partie
des primés à cannes jamel debbouze sami
bouajila
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
et puis l'un de ces sommes à vos côtés
ayoub l'allègue bonsoir vous avait 87
ans vous étiez là de ces tirailleurs
d'abord les images du film et du
phénomène créé par ce film qui est aussi
c'est l'occasion de le rappeler une
coproduction france 2 pascal deschamps
mathieu de rejouer ce soir-là à cannes
faut-il l'avouer la france re
découvraient le visage de ces soldats
oubliés vieux messieurs à la démarche
hésitante vétéran de la libération aux
côtés des acteurs qui pour la première
fois nous font vivre leur exploit au
cinéma
indigène raconte de 1943 à 1945 les
campagnes d'italie et de france d
engager des colonies
je veux que mon fils quand il va aller à
l'école que sa prof d'histoire à 8,10
voilà il y avait des miles avant il y
avait des juifs y avait des pieds noirs
ils ont défendu la france
on a libéré la corse on a libéré toulon
on a libéré marseille où l'on découvre
pêle mêle le courage et des différences
de traitement de promotions ou des
soldes que personne ne remette en cause
on se bat tous ensemble contre hitler
pour la liberté l'égalité et la
fraternité
là bas maintenant de cette liberté
tout cet égard didier et surtout 17
points mérités j'étais en colère - de
fouiller dans l'histoire et d'apprendre
tous ces éléments qui sont dans ce film
que je vais pas dévoiler ici
mais la leçon que j'ai reçu c'est que
ces hommes que je suis allé interviewer
pendant des mois elle n'avait pas de
colère comme ça direct sport à la guerre
130 mais mike détracteurs beurre 90
films a eu quatre comédiens dans le vent
de l'histoire persuadé de servir une
cause juste et qui espère toucher les
jeunes et ça marche
je trouve ça dommage qu'on les besoins
d'un film pour pardonner pour faire
bouger la plupart ce moment quoi
s'attendre
pour que ces dames un filou tin un grand
film tout simplement et qui offre aux
enfants de l'immigration des héros qui
leur ressemble voilà sorte